joining me now is the cabinet office
Minister Nadim zahawi good morning well
Minister
um now you've written a newspaper
article this morning um calling on
conservative MPS to Rally around Liz
truss did you expect that you'd have to
be within a month of her election you'd
have to be begging your colleagues to
give her a break
so I wrote the article because I think
delay is our biggest enemy we've got two
years to demonstrate to the nation that
we can deliver deliver the growth plan
deliver the energy strategy that weans
us off expensive oil and gas being
imported to the United Kingdom by
investing in nuclear investing in
offshore wind onshore wind and of course
other Renewables
and I want my colleagues to obviously
Focus because
um you know any uh dither or delay will
end in defeat and that's what we don't
want to see we want to be able to
demonstrate to the nation as we have
done first couple of days in office Liz
truss put on and I was translated
exchecker who developed the plans the
biggest energy package to protect
households and businesses
probably in history is an enormous
intervention to make sure the households
can feel safe at Christmas that they'll
have the ability to keep the heating on
whilst Putin are you put in your in your
opening
remarks is using energy as a weapon
against us because of the help we're
putting into Ukraine and to get Ukraine
uh their country back so I I understand
that but the thing that you really most
apparently I read the article want to
delay is torium peace criticizing the
Prime Minister would you expect that
you'd have to do that well I want to see
Unity I want us to now that we've had a
leadership election we've got a prime
minister in place we've got 24 months to
deliver the cabinet office is
effectively I'm the Chief Operating
Officer of the government the CEO my
responsibility
um Liz has given us the priorities for
each department so let me bring that to
life for you in health it's about a b c
d so ambulance the backlog
care than GPS and dentists doctors and
dentists if we deliver that in the next
two years where people feel confident
they'll get their GPA appointment within
two weeks hopefully even earlier they'll
get a dentist appointment on the NHS
that we will actually finally deliver a
care system that is fit for purpose that
people can see and feel the difference
then we will we will absolutely I think
I'm confident going to the country and
saying give us another term I want to
give you a chance to talk about policy
in a second but let's just deal with the
politics um you're not the only ones
taken to newspapers this morning um
Penny mordant and trailer Braverman your
cabinet colleagues have written similar
pieces
um could this be the same Penny mordant
who was the first to publicly disagree
with the uh policy of let's wait and see
on inflation or earnings benefits or
could it be the same swallow Brotherman
who told a fringe meeting second day of
your conference that she thought the
u-turn on 45p was disappointing uh I
have to say isn't this a bit like the
arsonists turning up uh to a house fire
with a with a bucket saying oh we want
to help they're the ones who started
this well first of all you will know
true because you've been to you're a
veteran of party conferences party
conferences there's a way of telling me
I'm old no you're gonna put me off
butted this well
first of all as I said we'd been in
office
um under Liz truss uh for a very short
period of time when uh her late Majesty
sadly passed away and then we had to
obviously coordinate and it was the
honor of my life to coordinate
um the funeral and commemoration for her
majesty
um and of course we have cabinet
Collective responsibility but we've
literally had everything only one
cabinet meeting that hasn't stopped us
doing the work we I have as in my role
as Chief Operating Officer been making
sure all those targets
um are now unpacked there's
um
targets by by time and of course
um by milestone in place for each of
those ministers you're not dealing with
this money which is about your
colleagues yes who were the first to
criticize uh the chancellor and the
prime minister in various ways suddenly
deciding that they're calling for Unity
I mean for goodness sake well so let's
just be serious no it is very serious
because actually both Penny and swella
are part of that Team part of that
cabinet is we've got cabinet Collective
responsibility on the Universal Credit
um uh uplift the Secretary State at the
department for work in patches Chloe
Smith there's a process you know that
there's a process the actual data from
September is still not uh fully uh
collated the one thing I would tell your
viewers is list trust will always be on
the side of helping the most vulnerable
the 8 million most vulnerable households
are not only getting the advantage of
the energy price cap she's putting the
average household not paying more than
two two and a half thousand pounds for
their energy but also the 1200 pounds
that we'd previously got in place that
we're getting to those households so
we'll always be on the side of those
households that need the most help but
until we have the process complete at
DWP no decision has been made on the
Universal Credit
um uh on the benefits operating but if I
really say so this is this is unusual
for you you're you're still not
answering my question the two cabinet
ministers who have written these
articles knew all that you've just said
when they went out of the Conservative
Party Conference and said oh no we're
not going to stick to the line and wait
uh until the chance was decided on this
benefits thing Penny Morden said I'm for
inflation uh when she knew that the the
cabinet line was not to say anything
day after U-turn says actually don't
think that was right and they're now
saying calling for Unity this doesn't
make any sense
when you are moving at PACE and delay uh
is um your enemy yeah we have little
time we're 24 months to demonstrate to
the nation that we can deliver this
growth plan
um we can deliver the energy plan we can
deliver the infrastructure the health
care plan all these things
um we're moving you know incredibly if
Penny was here all swell as I said of
course we take cabinet Collective
responsibility on swella's point what
she was saying is this prime minister is
focused on tax take tax receipts coming
into the exchange to pay for the doctors
and nurses and teachers and police
officers that we want to see
um actually delivering for this country
that is you know perfectly sensible but
we have collect a cabinet Collective
responsibility and when we make a
decision on the Universal Credit on the
benefits uplift everybody we will row
behind all right let's let's talk about
policy the uh the Prime Minister
introduced a new phrase to us last week
the ant T growth Coalition now I suppose
that includes people who don't want
building on Green Belt people who don't
want fracking who people who like their
Villages just as they are and don't want
new housing Estates at the bottom of the
garden and people who think that we've
had far too much immigration and we
shouldn't be doing any more of that um
no sound to me like solid Tory voters so
isn't your strategy self-destructive you
are mischievously conflating consent of
the people versus actual policy on
delivery of a of a dynamic economy why
do I say that so let's take the issue of
immigration people absolutely right that
we want to Bear Down on bad migration so
if you look at say let me give you an
example on International students
International students are a A plus a
really positive thing for our
universities for our communities but if
you look at the number of dependents
that come with International students
you'd expect most of Massachusetts may
bring one dependent or if they are doing
a PhD they might bring their wife and
maybe a child or two there are some uh
people who are coming to study in the UK
who are bringing five six more people
with them is that right no because we
have to make sure that they actually
they're coming to legitimately study
here uh and of course that is the right
thing to do to look at bearing down on
um abuse of a system on the the other
side of of that equation uh on the
projects that we're trying to deliver so
let's look at gigabit Broadband we need
more uh Engineers who can splice the
actual
um uh uh technology together to deliver
Brigade Broadband if we need another two
or three hundred Engineers to come in to
be able to do that at PACE I think
people will support that if you look at
what we're doing on hold on what we're
doing on investment zones investment
zones are about local areas consenting
to having an investment zone that
includes your substantial amounts of
Residential Building of commercial
building that's a good thing on this is
on tapping into our gas assets okay just
before you go on to that right uh this
is a great picture you're painting yeah
when you say people who will support
that I take one person who's not going
to support it soiler Brevin who last
week said we want to get immigration
down to net below net 100 000. right now
it's net 239
000. she is one person who is not going
to agree with the words you've just said
honestly I'm gonna I'll answer that in a
very straightforward way because I have
a weekly meeting
um because I chair that meeting
um on both uh legal migration and of
course the illegal migration that we
want to stamp out um including the issue
around you know the small boats where
people are being
um you know having their lives put in
danger by these gangs we want to break
that business model with swella bravaman
in those weekly meetings because again
remember what I said to you at the
beginning time is against us delay is
our enemy we have to move at PACE to
deliver the stuff as the Chief Operating
Officer I do that as well as in those
meetings every week and she would agree
with me when I say to you we have to
bear down on the bad migration and make
sure that the economy and the big
projects I want to deliver the uh the
needs of those projects are met at speed
in the next 24 months because what Liz
wants to see is not just announcements
but delivery
when we next see her we'll ask her if
she really agrees but let's let's not
delay and let's get to the thing that I
think most people will be having on
their minds right now Winter's coming
energy uh is an issue the National Grid
says that no it's unlikely there could
be planned blackout do you agree with
that it's extremely unlikely so let me
again I I again cabinet office and my
responsibilities to chair those meetings
we've got a couple of things that that
are um things that we've done that help
us deal with
um winter and of course war on our
continent is the cause of
um uh you know us being very focused on
making sure we have the resilience in
place over winter what have we got we've
got the second largest LNG processing
infrastructure in Europe yeah with half
of our gas we produce here at home we
want to go further this year we've
increased our output by 26 percent on
gas we've got interconnectors with our
neighbors now what the National Grid is
saying is the extremely unlikely
scenario where there's issues in Europe
with the interconnectors
um and the cold snap
so but it's possible isn't it so it is
extremely unlikely but it's only right
that we you know plan for every scenario
but all I would say is we have a buffer
the same buffer as last year and so I'm
confident that come Christmas come you
know the cold weather we will continue
to be in that resilient place but it's
only right that we have
um you know we have actually looked at
every scenario okay now what the
National Grid is doing with off gem is
also actually you know having a a
communication
program to tell people how they can do
better we ourselves UK you will be able
to see
um how you can actually uh you know this
is interesting your home or your
business can serve energy because this
is very interesting so so the the the
the stories we've been hearing about the
government saying to uh Jacob response
Department that plan that you've got for
telling people how they can dial down
the amount of energy that they use there
will now be a government campaign and
government not Direction but uh
government information about how we can
all use less energy so
the the question you ask is about
spending 14 million pounds on a campaign
that I think is the wrong thing because
actually
um if you go on gov dot UK now you'll
see
um if you search how you know what tips
there are for you to be able to
um conserve more energy use energy
wisely the National Grid and off Gem and
actually a number of the energy
providers are using the direct
communication with households uh to be
able to say you know here are some
measures that you can take okay is it
going to tell us things like how we turn
down the boiler temperature is it going
to tell us what we do laundry we're not
doing is spending 14 million pounds on a
government campaign yeah okay you don't
have to spend money but um well let me
ask you you know you're the minister for
sorting stuff out really at the moment
um if I say to you what should I be
doing should I be doing my laundry at
night should I the Norwegians are
telling people shower with a friend uh
is that um is that what you're going to
be recommending so I think look the the
really positive thing that list trust
has done if you think through what she
did in the first two days is having that
energy price cap where the average
household will not pay more than two and
a half thousand pounds has two positive
things about that right
we haven't got all day I just want to
ask you it helps you be giving people
advice about things they ought to do to
re uh reduce the amount of energy they
personally use and we collectively so if
they go on gov dot UK there's lots of
advice on that
um and that National Lottery no not a
specific campaign but actually the
bearing down on the cost of energy for
households help people cope
um with war on our continent
um and make sure they have a safe
Christmas when it comes to their energy
consumption by the way it does one other
thing which we haven't talked about it
actually Bears down on inflation up to
five percent on inflation and that
fiscal responsibility will help then the
monetary policy that is the Independent
Bank of England be hopefully bring
inflation back under control as well we
are seeing this morning images of uh at
least one half of a bridge between
Russia and Crimea in the water
and as you've already suggested that is
part of the problem that we're facing to
do with energy and Foods uh shortages
potentially and so on
is this a turning point in that war do
you think
so when I was translating this Checker I
worked with Janet Yellen my opposite
number two in the united states in the
United States to get the political
agreement at G7 on the oil price cap so
that we don't allow Putin to profiteer
from excessively high prices of oil
um I think Mr Putin needs to end this
war and the way you end this war is by
actually pulling your troops from all of
the Ukraine
um as quickly as possible we will
continue to support the ukrainians in
their incredible Endeavor to get their
country uh back Ben Wallace spoke about
this at Party Conference the work that
he is doing that James cleverley is
doing at the department in development
and of course Aid that's going into uh
Ukraine uh it will continue
um and I think there's one way to stop
this war the only way to stop this war
is for Russia to withdraw from Ukraine
well that's not necessarily the case Mr
Putin thinks we understand that there
may be another way to stop this at War
which is the use of nuclear weapons and
Mr Biden has said that they think that's
a reality realistic Prospect Mr solenski
has said he thinks that's a realistic
Prospect does the British government
think that it's a realistic prospect
that Putin could use nuclear weapons
well British is unpredictable and I will
not
um wish to speculate as to
um what he does next the right thing to
do is to withdraw I think the Russian
people will have something to say if he
decides to give the order to use nuclear
weapons on people that he claims to be
his
um cousins and yeah I haven't had much
family so far have they I mean but the
main point I really want to ask you is a
year ago we didn't take what he said
seriously and we didn't we were
surprised frankly by February 24th it's
quite the opposite if you remember
Trevor we were actually front running
that story which irritated him we with
our allies the Americans we were telling
the world that Putin will invade he's
preparing for Invasion uh full-scale
Invasion when actually few people okay
in other parts of the world
um agreed with us
I wouldn't argue the toss with you about
that but if we are so uh if we know it
all what do we actually believe he is
likely to to do now will he or will he
not according to the briefings and
advice that you have be prepared to use
nuclear weapons we don't know it all we
have to continue to support the
ukrainians
um and of course they have to be the
ones in the lead on this
um they're the ones who are fighting for
their freedom fighting for our freedom
um you know if you go back a step Trevor
because you you you know this is
important to you you remember what Putin
did with Assad in Syria where there was
that red line about using chemical
weapons and we never actually followed
through because actually it was Ed
miliband at the time his little party he
would draw support to Cameron on that he
then took the Crimea and there was very
little impact now it is very different
now Europe the world's United in many
ways the free world's United in
supporting Ukraine to claim their
freedom and our freedom and safety back
thank you very much for your time this
morning thank you